all right these are the moments original  song and this one is available on  spotify and itunes and all this stuff  all right so  okay here we go  [Music]  do  [Music]  wake up in the morning  all i see is you  [Music]  the things i wanna do  over and over  [Music]  every time you've looked me in the eyes  [Music]  these are the moments  [Music]  is always better when i've got you near  nothing really bring me down don't make  me shed a tear  i know that you got my little heart in  here  [Music]  right  [Music]  [Music]  these are the moments  [Music]  these are the moments  [Music]  when you're still sleeping  [Music]  hard as you can  [Music]  [Music]  every time you look into my eyes and you  stay across the room  [Music]  a new  [Music]  these are the  [Music]  moments are the  [Music]  moments in the moments  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  these are the moments  [Music]  these are the moments  [Music]  [Music]  you